thank you very much for making me so
today I'll talk about this beauty
statistical estimation of matrix
products so this is joint work which
they would you so we work in the
standard communication model so we have
two party Allison a Bob Alice as a
matrix of hazard matrix and they want to
compute some function on the product of
these two matrix and our goal is again
to minimize the communication cost and
also the number of runs of the
communication so we consider a set of
statistical problems the first set of
problems
P known so we want to compute is just
the opinion of the of the product of the
two matrix matrices so when P is equal
to 0 this is simply the number of
nonzero entries of C and this
probability actually corresponds to the
size of a set intersection joy in
database so if we think each row of a as
a set and each column of B as I said so
our goal is just want to compute the
number of pairs AI BJ that they
intercept ok so when P is equal to 1
this correspond to the sum of the
entries of C it's it's basically it's in
the database setting it's the size of
the corresponding network joints and so
I want to say that those these two
problems the set intersection joy and
natural join they're arguably the most
important operations in relational
database this people really cares a lot
and the size estimation is the key to
query optimization so basically we want
to basically spend a lot very few
resources to try to estimate the size
then we can build the the operation tree
for for for for more complicated
operation abilities so when P is equal
to infinity this is just the maximum
entry of C so this corresponds to the
most similar pair a I in a BJ
so I just want to show you like
application of set intersection joints
so this is a application job this is a
scenario of job application so we have a
set of applicants and a set of openings
so each applicant has a set of skills
and each openes requires a set of skills
so what we want to do is find all the
candidate applicant open in pairs that
they intersect they have a common skill
okay
so we will recommend those kind of pairs
for interview for example so this is
just one application of I think the
second joint so we also study the
problem of heavy hitters so here
basically we won't just want to output
or the entries of C that is larger than
some threshold five times the P normal
so often like we cannot compute this
exactly so we just target for
approximate version of this so basically
we want to find one output all the CIJ
is that bigger than five times the
Phenom J and do not output anything
they're smaller than Phi minus epsilon
fraction of this of a pin of C and for
those in between we don't care okay so
this corresponds to the similarly join
in the database setting again this is
also actually very important probably
database okay so let me show you our
main results so for simplicity so for
simplicity let's assume like we are
working on square matrix so M is equal
to n so for P norm so what we get is a
two round algorithm using and over
absolute bits of communication up to
some point look vector so we can
approximate the pin on of of the product
of these two matrix with the effect of 1
plus Epsilon so for P equal 0 this
improves the previous without so we have
a paper earlier with Duke Ryan and David
so we so we got an upper bound and over
from square this is actually a very
simple almost trivial algorithm like you
just ask
use everything sketching so it's very
simple each color of the off C so we
prove this by effect of Epsilon okay and
the same paper gives a lower bound and
over absolute or power 12 2 over 3 yeah
I will talk about some ideas how to get
this little lower bound in a few slides
and if we restrict the communication to
me one way then this is actually optimal
so this readout I would have thought use
separation between one main
communication and the multi run the
communication p-norm estimation so for
our affinity where we get is a constant
round algorithm that approximate our
infinity wielding factor of 2 plus
epsilon using n to the power 1.5 over
epsilon bits still up again up to some
point log factors and for general
counsel for general approximation factor
we get a similar result into a 1 point 5
divided by Kappa Kappa is the
approximation ratio so we actually we
can show that these results are actually
close to optimal so we show that if we
want to approximate this within a factor
of 2 then basically we have to send
everything so so n square is the lower
bound if we want to approximate with the
effect of Kappa then basically this
without start up to some load vector
okay so these are all for binary matrix
so if the matrix general matrix take
arbitrary integer values then the bound
is actually much higher so it's n square
over Kappa square Kappa is the
approximation ratio
so this is for our infinitely so for
happy hater for binary matrix we get
constant again constant round and
communications and plus five over from
square and for general matrix is
slightly higher so basically it's two
things multiplied okay and all of these
are for square matrix before the Katanga
matrix means that those results are it
can be easily extent two tangos matrix
basically just replace some of the end
not all of there's some other end to end
so this is our results so let me briefly
mention like what previously what
results are known previously so as
mentioned like so our earlier paper
studied the F 0 none of the product so
there are a number of papers look at
distribution and in iam algebra problem
but the focus is on the compute some
statistics on as sum of the two matrix
instead of the product of the just two
matrix and this similar problems have
been studied in RAM model so there's
quite a few papers on the RAM model but
surprisingly this is I think it's a very
simple clean problem not much work has
been done in the you know distributed
model so this is I know so in the rest
of talk I will give you a to as the
simple algorithms for infinity and they
are 0 and I also mentioned some to I did
some ideas of the lower bound proofs so
let's start with the 1 plus epsilon
approximation of the l01 not so so here
so here's a high-level idea so what we
do is we first performed rough
estimation of the number of nonzero
entries of the the the result matrix C
and then we use this rough estimation to
partition the raus of of the see two
groups so that lows in the single have
suniye number of nonzero entries
and then we sample the rolls each group
was probated proportional to the the
estimated average number of nonzero
entries of the rows of the group and
then we use those sample rows to
estimate the number of nonzero entries
of C so a more accurate level so how to
implement those things so this is the
actual implementation so we have two
parameter beta we said to be square root
of epsilon absolutely the approximation
factor and lo is we said to be one with
absolute so let's let's assume that
communication starts from Bob so we use
the previous algorithm basically like a
sync simple linear sketch to get a 1
plus beta approximation of the of the
number of nonzero entries of the rows of
each rows of C ok and then Alice after
getting this information Alice can
petition those arrows of C this is the
estimation of C to a set of groups log
log in of a beta groups so that the the
the the rows each group they have
similar both nonzero entries and then
for each group basically L is just
sample each rows with with a probability
like proportional to the average number
of non-zeros of the groups in this group
this is just a normalization factor and
then let a pride to be the those sample
rows we can pad others by 0 and then Bob
said so Allison those sample rows or the
sample matrix a pride for Bob and Bob
just compute C prime that is product of
a prime B and then after getting the C
prime just the USO so Bob King computes
the number of nonzero entries of of the
rows of C prior their property whiskey
and then sum up so that's that's we can
show that this is a biased estimation
the variance is small okay and the
number of the communication cost is
basically so communication happens here
in the step 1 step 3 also step 1
so basically it's
it's it's it's directly from the
previous readout so it's n over beta
square so we said meter squared - B
squared and it's well epsilon so this is
1 over Epsilon okay so we cannot like so
so so previous without just directly set
beta equal to epsilon so this is why we
have an option square but this is too
much so we have to use like a larger
like a possum in ratio this is what do I
mean by a rough estimation okay and this
step takes so because yeah so this is
yeah this step also takes a map some
bits of communication so this is
basically the upper bounds
so I talked about lower bound so this
lower bound is actually our previous
paper
so for prove a lower bound for this
problem let me first introduce two
premium two problems the first is when
the well known that it is shown is i
guess all of you probably all of you
knows so we have Edison Bob and each of
them have a n bits vector and they won't
just want to see if they have colonies
that oppose X I and why I equal to 1 and
there's exist on how the input
distribution that some of this sorry
this problem with good probability it's
Omega and communication so this is a
well-known result and the second
component is also widely used primitive
problem cut having so again like we have
two parties each of them has n bits
vector so let WI to be the XO of X on Y
I so our goal is to compute to
determining like whether the son of this
WI is less than less than M over 2 minus
scrote m or bigger than M over 2 plus
squirrel and and in the middle we don't
care ok
so again we can show that the exist
somehow the import distribution that
solving gap hamming with the culpability
needs to learn so it's a slightly
different we need to learn at least
linear number of W is with well by well
means the motor information between
WI and and this total cash transfer
protocol transcript is at least Omega 1
so this is what do I mean by look well
so this is 2 component we use and then
so this is the hard distribution for for
the L 0 estimation problem so we so I
will set the value of M shortly but so
basically for each I for each pair AI bi
this is chosen as a instance of the
heart
so it's choose like instance of this as
dystonias problem and according to a
heart equal distribution mu B and then
we define a sum of a B to be just a sum
of the output of this M set that
intersection intersection join and then
we can show that with high probability
the L 0 norm of of a B is equal to sorry
the sum of the sum a b-plus this this
actual turn roughly M square okay and
then so we can show that it's hard to
approximate this sum a be within a small
arrow so what we do is we can show that
any randomized algorithm that computes
the sound with probability 0.99 up to an
additive arrow
scrout n needs to spend we need to spend
like Omega M times n communication
between them right so you go to take the
product of AI and so the country is
Eternia so this turns counts I you know
is USD next slide
yes it work ants so this term basically
just turn counts like Isaiah and the BI
and this turns counts
area and the BJJ not equal to I so this
is why we have this so we have like M
rows and M columns is basically every a
and BJ will kind of intersect under our
hard into input distribution yes yes
so this is the way you add this time
sorry I should mention this yeah okay so
how to prove this basically the
high-level idea is that okay to to
approximate this somewhere we have to
solve embedded gap Jaime instance and by
previous lemma to solve this gap coming
in instance up to arrow of M we have to
learn basically a linear number of the
bits WI and each WI is at put of setting
to intersection destroy nice problem so
that means if we are to solve basically
we have to solve this set test Ranas
problem which needs Omega M bits so this
two terms multiply this is why we have M
times n but the actual and the actual
argument is actually more involved like
we have to modify the distribution for
set disjointness and gap having to make
sure that they can compose and we can
even have to modify the definition of
those promise a little bit about those
are details that I don't want to really
get into about but this is high-level
idea okay
and then we set m to be this value 1
over epsilon to the power 2 over 3 to
make the arrow
squared M to be absolute times the arrow
0 know of the product of these two
matrix okay so this gives us this lower
bound
so this is a high-level sketch of the
lower bond proof so me if if you want to
only remember one slide of the talk this
is a slide so the open the main question
left by our work is in the follow us so
we have upper bound of sorry I should
put tutor here so but if you don't care
log vectors then it's n over epsilon and
lower bound is a no option to a power
two or three so so questions like which
one's the right complexity maybe none of
them is so maybe there's something
between so we still don't know we spend
a lot of efforts try to improve this
upper bound so far we haven't succeeded
but but I mean I had like lower bound
this two over three looks like a bit
weird I never see I've never seen like
such power like two over three so I
don't know like which was it's a case so
the difficulty here is like me we can
have set this M to be larger than 1 over
absolute to the power 2 over 3 because I
only had the distribution we choose
exactly what I mentioned so each AI will
intersect with each BJ J not equal to I
so with high probability and this turn
if we set this M to be too large then
this term will dominate the zero know of
the product obviously and I mean this is
probably the I would like to think is
like ok on this scenario the primitive
promise overlaps me overlap is probably
not the best of words to describe this
but but this is how I am issue I have in
mind the picture happy mind so and I
guess maybe like if you want to prove
this higher lower bound some maybe some
new techniques
I know what hit Sloane Square is a bone
that holds even for one way that's a
body weight for one way I know Epsom
square that's for one way yeah that's
the type I mean I'm tired understand
where's the difference between one-way
and two-way comes in because these lower
bounds seem to be working in either
model the gap Hamming in just joined us
oh I see they give a weaker bond of n
over epsilon to the 231 for one way yeah
so one way like if you use these things
you can still use these things so these
things works for unbounded number of
runs right so you can still use it for
one round but you get the worse lower
bound
yeah one way one way we don't do this
okay so okay so let's move to our
infinity so forever infinity we prove
like - we've got algorithm for 2 plus
epsilon approximation so so here's the
idea so the idea is to try to sample
this matrix C by sometime in the
following so actually we sent we kind of
sample directly on C with sample a
basically we created like a hierarchy of
sample matrix a 1 a 2 a 3 so a 1 is like
we subset sample every entries of a with
probability 1 over Epsilon and this is a
hierarchy and c1 c2 is just this product
of a 1 B and a to be so we want to keep
doing this and our idea is to sort of
sub sample C to a level L such that
first L we hope L to be as large as
possible in other words the L 1 norm of
C L to be as small as possible if
because if this is very small then we
you will see like what happened in the
analysis and then on the other hand the
if it no of CL is still a good
approximation of the L if you know of
the original matrix C ok so so this is a
high-level idea and and let's see like
how we implement this so it's actually
very straightforward again we have two
parameters this is number of total
number of levels and this is a parameter
we use like in the second step of the
algorithm so so the substance the
substance calling can be done in one
pass so Alice this sample a and send
some information to B&B Bob and Bob can
compute those CLS actually exactly
and the communication cost for this is
is actually very small because L because
basically what L is do is just a SEM
so for a al it at least don't have to
send the whole air al just send the
number of ones of each column of Al then
then that's enough so it's kind of
almost linear okay and and then what Bob
do is Bob compute the local computation
right so Bob cards are the CEO C 1 C 2 C
3 so we can compute find the L star that
is smallest L for which the L 1 norm of
C L is no more than gamma times N
squared and then we focused on this
particular level L star what we do then
is so let so we look at this 2 matrix a
a I'll stand B so let u J to be the
number of ones of the J's calling of a
star and the V J to be number ones of
the ratio of B and then we compare it to
value if the if u J is less than V J
then Alice sent the the whole row to to
Bob and the Jays Colin so it's just kind
of a L star to Bob and otherwise pops
and the J's row of B to Alice and then
use those up this exchanging of rows and
columns and they can compute two matrix
so they can compute the CI CA and CB
respective a so that the son of CNSE B
is equal to C L star okay and then they
output a max of so they compute so Alice
can compute the Iovino of CA and Bob can
compute a infinitive of CB they
improperly security then they turn the
max of these two okay so this cost a
one-round this is local computation
discussed two lands because Alice also
need to know what is L star right and
then the last line cost one round so in
toto it's it's four round protocol and
so correctness is actually very simple
so first me we can show that
if we look at this particular level we
can show that the l if you know of CL
star after properly scaling is a good
approximation of f zero no of the
original matrix C and then this is like
what we have right this is what we have
this is a simple fact
so that means max obvious - is that -
plus optional talks about -
approximation of the elephant norm of C
F star and combine these two facts we
get this is the correctness of the
algorithm and the communication cost is
actually dominated by the exchange of
this rows and columns so so so we
analyze this cast by two cases first
it's like both this knob of one sing
Collins and the number of ones in rows
basically both you G and a B G a large
but we can say that means they're not I
mean so many days because the l1 know of
CL stars is small because we just - J
will contribute like u J times V J mass
to the to the l1 know of this matrix so
if this is small then they're not so
many
so the communication is bounded
otherwise it's even simpler right so
because one of them are small so that
means like the amount of information we
send is small this is a high-level idea
and we can probably balance those things
and again this n to the power 1.5 or
Webster that's basically the analysis so
very quick proof of the lower bound this
this lower bound is actually very simple
so we are going to prove a lower bound
for an affinity of C so it's basically a
simple reduction to set again to a set
this Jonas so what Alice has is X is a
bits is N squared over four bit string
and Bob has again like mo for s square
of four bit string so what Alice - is
petitioners best string to n over two
chunks each of size n over two and then
use it to construct a matrix apply
dimension n over 2 by M and M of 2 and
then we construct this block matrix so a
prime is the one of the component and
this is an identity matrix and this is 2
they're basically 0 matrix and the
dimension of a is again n by n and the
same thing similar seemed to be the pops
above the zeros is here so it'd be price
is the left button okay and then we can
show that the L infinity know of a
product of n B is equal to the elephant
normal sum of a prime B Prime and which
is 2 if if the this one is returns 1 and
the 1 a device so this is a whole
reduction that means like you cannot
really approximate things better than
you couldn't - so that's that's it so
let me wrap up so this is the main
results of their paper so one
perceptional approximation of the p-norm
of the product of matrix using n over
epsilon communication in the two runs
and we got for L infinity we got the
tool plus apps from approximation using
n to a power 1.5 or absolute and the
communication takes four runs and
there's some other results for
heavy-hitters which I haven't which I
haven't talked about so there are a
couple of open problems
so this problem really mentioned so so I
want to close the gap reaching upper
bounds lower bounds for our zero and so
for every Finity so this proto crack
cost for UND's so again I don't think
like for is the is the right bounce so
so why Ron is important because me
especially in practice starting around
is very expensive people really want
like one run dog to run the
communication so if you talk to database
people I need to log in runs they will
not be interested so even four runs is a
bit expensive so can we reduce this to
two runs for example
and and for happy tell me we only get
hotter pounds upper bounds and we
haven't thought about lower bounds so
everything is open okay so I think
that's all I want to say
[Applause]
in question you have this one round
lower bound which is dependent on one
riffs on squared all right are you aware
of any other problems where the
dependence on excellent on this
approximation factor
so here like basically we show like one
run a two-round are different but if you
ask like okay is there any without has
the round supply metering the either
either communication car lower bound I
think we didn't prove but I think
there's also a separation yeah in
general like one round the versus
multiple round I think there should be a
lot of lead out
thank you again
[Applause]